[Music]
climate Justice what do we want climate
Justice this is the bare minimum um this
some people say that this is a first
step but we've already had first steps
and that hasn't led us anywhere the
emissions are still increasing we are
experiencing record highs um this this
text is toothless and it is nowhere even
close to being sufficient to keep us
within the 1.5 degree limit it is a stab
in the back for those most vulnerable
and it was undemocratic it was signed
when
when many Island states were not in the
room and that is completely unacceptable
and we cannot talk about climate Justice
without having the most affected in the
room I think this cop has once again
proven that the cop processes are not
working in our favor um they are not
designed to solve the climate crisis um
they are more working as an alibi for
world leaders to say that oh we we
signed this and they're not actually
doing anything if the cops would have
led to anything we would have seen
results by now there have been 28 cops
and that has not led us anywhere but
moving still in the wrong
direction as long as we don't treat the
climate crisis as a crisis and as long
as we keep Lobby interests influencing
these texts and these processes we are
not going to get anywhere we need to
address the root
causes